you
[Music]
but coming to our breakout session about
artificial intelligence and security it
is my great pleasure to host today three
of our leading lights in computer
security and I get to ask some questions
around what does it mean to have
artificial intelligence and security and
today we're going to focus on three
framing questions first question is what
can artificial intelligence learn from
security we are all extremely excited
about the potential of AI we know there
are downsides the security feel is one
where we've sort of thought about
downsides and tax for a long time what
are some things to consider what are
some things we can learn from that field
the second question is what the security
learn from artificial intelligence
you'll hear today about some surprising
new results in computer security powered
by the techniques that you may be
familiar with from machine learning and
other branches of artificial
intelligence and finally we'll spend a
little bit of time talking about what
happens after AI succeeds we do believe
that every kind of business process
every kind of part of our lives will be
transformed by the different parts of
artificial intelligence we're building
as you may have heard in harry shum talk
so looking a little bit further out
assuming this actually works which we
believe it will what is security going
to look like what will it look like when
an algorithm controls who gets jobs who
gets food and who gets rewarded and
these of course are not nearly as
theoretical as they sound I actually
heard a very interesting this anecdote
at the reception the other day how many
people use the the website Zillow how
many people like check the price of
their home on the website Zillow
everybody well that's a limited form of
artificial intelligence it's are trying
to figure out how much your home is
worth and they had a change to their
algorithm which caused someone's home to
lose fifty thousand dollars just like
that so we're already living in this
world and it's my pleasure to introduce
dawn song known you could raise your
hand
dawn comes to us from University of
California Berkeley where she has done
fantastic work and all fields of
computer security actually my very first
papers was with you Don
tie suit Kim comes to us from Georgia
Tech and then Mike Walker who caught
just joined Microsoft from DARPA so dawn
I'd like to turn it over you to give
your perspective on these questions and
then we'll have a discussion with
several others
great thanks thank you yeah I'm Sam Sam
from UC Berkeley and so this session
will cover three key questions as
they've just mentioned due to time
limits I will mostly focus on the first
question what a I can learn from
security and I'll briefly touch on the
few other questions and so we're living
in this exciting time and especially for
us who have done working in security
which is also very exciting questions as
an intersection between ains security
amiable elohim's
AI can be an enabler for security on the
other hand security can be enabled for
AI and in particular in this repair we
will focus more on how security
continues with people by providing
stronger integrity confidentiality and
also preventing misuse of area so and
for a on the security video is about AI
in the presence of attacker and it's
really important for us to consider AI
in the presence of attacker for a number
of reasons history has shown that the
attacker always follow the footsteps of
the new technology development or
sometimes even research and I think Mike
return will give you even more
interesting historical perspective on
that and also this time the stake is
even higher with a ii/3 I can choose a
more in more systems a party will have
higher and higher incentives and to
attack I and also as AI becomes point
more capable the consequences of misuse
by attackers will also become more more
severe and when we look at AI in the
presence of attacker essentially there
are two categories to protect to
progress that we need to pay attention
to one is how the attacker can attach a
I buy for example causing the new system
to now to produce the intended and
corrected results are even more so
causing the learning system to produce
target
outcome designed by the attacker and
they can cause the AI system to leak
sensitive information about individuals
and to adjust these problems we need
better security in the learning system
and the other starts as the attacker can
try to missing the eye to attack other
systems and and in this case we actually
need to solve even had a problem not
only to improve security for the winning
systems but also at the same time we
need to actually provide stronger
security as a system and again in the
target we mostly focus on the first part
and in particular what we can do about
securing the a eye systems or what kind
of problems can arise when the attacker
try to attack a eye and what can we do
about it so probably a lot of you have
seen those on one hand people in new
systems have been making amazing
adventures and such as our goal and you
know reaching human level performance
and image nuts dataset and so on but on
the other hand unfortunately people in
systems are very very easily fooled
so in this example on the left-hand side
these are the original images which are
practically classified by a you know
based image class classifier and the
middle columns are was called
adversarial perturbations
so and here these are magnify so you can
seen them otherwise very very small to
human eyes you can barely see them and
the right-hand columns these are called
our three examples what they are are
they are the original images with the
our three perturbations added as you can
see here to human eyes you can barely
see the differences between the original
images and there were two examples
persecute the image classifiers and
essentially these are three examples
there should cause the classifiers to
misclassified and so we have some a lot
of unification in the area of Avatar
example potential to precise image
classification tasks actually ever three
examples are really prevalent in the
training systems for example we've
looked at other personal model classes
for
models beep reinforcement learning and
so on and alternatives as these attacks
and actually be effective even when the
target model is not known so previous
work you mostly focus on when the target
model is known you know the architecture
you know the weight but we our work also
shows that even in the matchmakers where
the target model is unknown
such attacks can be very effective so
here just very quickly show you some
examples the first example is the
generative models including the models
you have inputs that go through an
encoding stage that general producer
solution vector which goes through the
decoder station where the originally
input is trying to reconstruct the
original input and this guarantee models
are very useful for lots of different
applications and one of those
applications is image compression and
the recent work has shown that in our
workspace the image compression has it
reaches state-of-the-art and here we can
consider an attack attack scenario for
example a lot of the security
surveillance cameras what they do is
that they actually record the images and
then they compress it and in the threw
away the original images only store the
compressed version and later on when the
law enforcement comes back to
investigate a currency they will try to
decompress the of the storage compress
images
try to reconstruct the original crime
scene so here we're not here to attack
scenario where the attacker tries to
generate some
essentially adversarial perturbation
protect version of the original images
here it's a seven but I think some other
food preservation economists an
adversary example and then once we go
through the compression stage and then
go through the decompression stage as
you can see that the compression stage
try to reconstruct the original input
but the operation here will reconstruct
into something completely different
instead of a server you can shine into
an egg and you can see the consequences
of this if this actually has been used
to English security surveillance camera
example that I mentioned so here let's
look at some actual examples of how
vulnerable these generative models can
be here's an example where these are the
original images
from the MMS hydrating teachers
signature to the strangers intercepts
and this is a reconstruction of the
original images using a generative model
and as you can see this reconstruction
of the original images works very well
but now let's say that the attacker
wants to generate our serial example
versions of these original images so
that the absolutely encoding and
decoding stage will actually generate
into something like this tag images 0
so here are the examples of the other
serial examples version of the original
images and they're here as a
reconstruction of the advert examples as
you can see they are all turned into
something like this tagging image and
this is a studio detective analyzed you
can see this our serial example version
of narration images changing to
something similar to the tracking image
and here is for the free space effect
where again the aperture examples of the
original version are
during reconstruction contingencies
something very close to the target image
so that's the example of our opportunity
model here is another example that we've
looked at in the deep reinforcement
learning setting and so a pity
reinforcement learning is very popular
these days
the for example ethical actually using
some of these techniques and here's an
example alpha a deep reinforcement
learning change it into playing the
video game Tom as you can see here
actually played fairly well and in this
case actually it changed to play to the
next V word but here we want to look at
it what happens when the attacker try to
attack a different agent so for this
engine to what it does is that it takes
the input as the input video frame and
then the neurons now are essentially
it's the policy that will try to given
the input framing or try to predict the
action so then what's for the attack
here especially the attack is trying to
add this adversary perturbation to the
input frame and then and then
essentially try to fold the range agent
and what we see here is that the
attacker actually has a very successful
and we can generate a insert a very
similar perturbation so that the learned
agent
then the same agent which has me very
successful early on beverage in some
extra work 20 now after the avatar is
officially injected into the input frame
and now that the same brain agent
completely fails the task and wishes the
minimum the word negative 20 and also we
will attach even smarter attacker
strategies where the attacker used to
learn the value function to try to try
to guide the attack to figure out when I
need to insert the other serve
perturbations so it doesn't need to
insert in every video frame and I only
need to insert in a very small fraction
of the video frames where still makes
the attack sort of successful if into
the read the value function is estimated
about how much in Reverse verses the
Asian market at the stage so here is an
example this is the original input input
frame how the agent behaves like what
you saw earlier and these are the
examples where as you can see two human
eyes and the venue to look exactly the
same the case of a super efficient
generator was so small after
conversation actually they are identical
and then in this case the middle the
middle column as well as the output over
to Federation and refriended as you can
see the detect completely failed and
under the reactant side column is the
one we only interact to adversary
perturbation guided by the value of
function in a very small fraction of the
video frames and also as you can see the
the agent completely fails so again so
this is the example showing that the
adversarial examples are really
prevalent in the training system and
also the whole community investigating a
lot of defenses I had to remove the
slides because there's nine of time but
the short answer here is that the action
has been over like a 60 70 papers
written just in the last two years
proposing very different types of
defenses against these attacks and the
today we still don't have a good
solution and survivor always talked
about our two examples fully learning
system as the inference time
our cultivation attacks they are
Caucasian also for the linear system as
a chain time that causes either poison
attack and the Microsoft a teacher about
the example can be seen as an example of
the data poison attack and I'll be
essentially are in the area of
adversarial machine learning it's about
how machine learning in the presence for
adversaries and this eMeter machine
learning is particularly important for
security critical systems so I strongly
believe that security will be one of the
biggest challenges in the point a I and
the series and motivators certificate
how we can improve the security after
the new system and there are many
challenges for securing a learning
system and as a teacher different levels
in particular at the circuit level
learning level and distributed level so
at the structure level the quality we
want to ensure there is no structural
abilities such as profit or flows and
access control issues where I will
enable the attacker to take it over to
take control over the linear system
through exploiting structure
vulnerability so luckily and this is the
area that we are very familiar with even
though there are still lots of often
challenges but the existing techniques
that we have developed over the past
decades existing software security form
of attrition and verification techniques
will apply and vintage some examples of
act in my personal work of a last twenty
circuit taking different approaches
defensive
reactive defenses in a person being and
secured by construction always
approaches for solving software security
problems and all these techniques
essentially apply to security for
learning systems at the software level
so to say that the big open challenges
for security of linear systems is at the
learning level and they are number of
different challenges in this area and
again due to thermal imager I will only
give you a few examples the principal
disadvantage sample that we can learn
from Social Security to me as well
it says how to evaluate this training
systems and it's very important for
security to evaluate this linear system
and
events not just normal events and this
actually is a slide that I use in my
undergrad security class that I teach
and stress to everyone of my class a
student in my class is about the
difference between regression testing
versus security testing and for software
systems and the difference is that for
regression testing that's a typical just
you know software testing with almost
program on normal inputs with the go to
prevent normal users from encountering
areas where for security to evaluate the
security of a server system it's not
sufficient to just to regression testing
it's really important to do security
testing and by security women that we
actually need to run program of normal
our serial input and the goal is to
prevent attackers from finding this
exploitable errors before us and
similarly for learning systems we also
need to make the distinction between
regression testing and security testing
regression testing as and also this can
be done as training and testing stages
so regression testing is basically water
every single machining equipment as done
today
and so it has our normal input and also
in particularly even once in a depends
today the teacher view should be similar
to the Trinity no distribution and we
try to the goal is to estimate
generalization error but however for
evaluating the security of the learning
system is not sufficient to just do
regression testing where you need to do
security testing and again here the
security testing is that we need to test
the security of the learning system of
normal our third input similar to the
adversary example that I mentioned
earlier and with a go to estimating
resiliency against ever dream so that
one and a challenge the knowledge
challenge is that we actually need to be
able to reason that complex non symbolic
programs o as a whole community we have
decades of experience on reasonable
symbolic programs and for most of us we
are actually supervising very familiar
with the symbolic programs these are
like our consistent file systems and so
on and there is semantically defined our
logic and again we've had decades of
experience and developed techniques and
tools for logic and symbolic reasoning
including
Pervis SMT solvers and so on and and in
fact I will see the way of mph and area
are formally verified system so these
are just a few examples where we have
formally verified this micro kernels are
consistent and so on with the formally
proven guarantees of certain correctness
and security properties and due to
powerful formal verification tools and
technical teams and dedicated to these
tasks even though in this domain we
still have a lot of challenges and in so
we've had decades of experiences and
techniques and tools developed however
the big challenges is really in the
domain of announcing public programs let
the people in systems that we are using
today and here we really have a lot of
lots of open questions and challenges
that as a whole community we have very
very little experience with for example
for this and learning systems for these
non symbolic programs we have no
precisely specified properties and codes
how do you precisely specify if your
goal is not to hit a pedestrian for
self-driving cars how do you even
specify what is a pedestrian and also we
have no good understanding of a
harmonious systems work and
unfortunately and the traditional
symbolic routing techniques really at
this level mostly to not apply and
furthermore we also have challenges in
how we can design new attitudes and
approaches with a stronger generalized
generalization and security guarantees
this is also a huge open challenges
after exams the previous session is
improvable
you know learning algorithms provoke
indeed for any algorithms and so on
so I'll just briefly give an example of
our recent work in a very limited domain
as a first step towards this direction
and this domain is in neuro program
synthesis where an intention we treat
neural networks to try to learn certain
programming tasks such as addition 13
and so on and there has been a long line
of working this domain including works
from Google and in mind 2 and so on
and unfortunately previous work is they
all suffer from mental challenges one is
Rachel mr. on
mr. Lim programs do not currently the
linear programs do not generalize well
and you learn how to do addition with
significant numbers they won't
generalize to know how to do addition
463 G numbers and the other challenges
are even if empirically the learned new
programs succeed in all the tests but
still there's no proven guarantees that
they have actually professionalisation
rather than programs like even if you
see that they to calculate addition for
up to 30 digital numbers you do know
what how they will be have for thirty
one to two two numbers so in our work
and making you programming accurately
generalized fabrication we propose a new
approach using recursion into introduced
accretion to new programs and they
recruit some new programs use nutrition
attention we can a problem is reduced to
subproblems family into its base
confusion with reduction rules
so where do you want the best paper
Awards at I see I I clear the top
different a substituent conference this
year and especially with this approach
where we show that for the first time
that we can to provide the proof of
generalization for for this for this
event you know programs and also using
this approach it can generalize much
much fraction and this and so from this
work we show that's the program
architecture actually is very important
for proved ability and this is also
something that we have learned from the
traditional software systems this is
real in touch will design programs with
good architectures that are easier to
prove properties of with arbitrary
programs that code such as Perl code
actually very difficult to prove new job
and hence going forward I think even for
foreigner in our opinion so we want to
consider and reclusive amounted on your
architectures which are easier to recent
proven generalize and also the more open
question and such for more general tasks
what can we do what kind of new
educational approaches that we can
develop to universe to internalization
and security properties for this project
ask and
really the key question is can we have
Provo guarantees of generalization and
security properties for this ranging
systems and also another challenge is
how we can reason about how to compose
component as we build a large and
complex systems everyday requires the
compositional reasoning where each
components can provide abstraction and
the hierarchical compositional reasoning
can prove properties of the whole system
and the key questions are how can we do
abstraction composition reasoning for
non symbolic programs and again these
are just a few examples of the list is
actually very very long a lot of really
open questions at the loonie level and
also there are lots of open questions
that efficiency level as well as the
digital level each agent makes a local
decisions so how can we make sure that
pretty local decisions can achieve good
global decision so these are just some
examples of how security can learn from
hi I can learn from security essentially
how search engine is improper to AI and
also under the other so excited AI
clinical potential security applications
as well since the acquisition key is
actually a clear example being used in
security applications and then the other
security application including using
deep learning for better vulnerability
detection some of the work after has
been done and Microsoft and frog
detection is a great application for as
machining and deepening in security
applications and also recently we've
done some work at using deep learning
for analyzing program boundaries for
similarity detection and for
vulnerability to touching as well and
one key question I think always think
about applying machine learning to
secure applications as well where to
mention any applicable in security
properties in security applications so
for example the example summation - like
the structure vulnerabilities at the
circuit level these structure
vulnerabilities oftentimes we have a lot
of programs verification program
analysis techniques developed for that
and I again the time is very short I
don't have time to go into the details
so those questions you know whether
those kind of applications actually
output with a mission in came to birth
today but however I will say machine
learning is really most needed when
there's no precise formal property and
specifications because for software
vulnerabilities such as memory to t-bone
abilities and so on and this precise
formal definition but we're not we have
many security problems that we
concentrate like a spam protection
account compromised detection detecting
vice versa humans there is no precise a
for most specification for these
problems and hence actually for these
problems machine learning is the only
solution we have today for this type of
security issues right and then so this
is how you know the intersection between
AI NS security what I wanted to enter as
like water inventions the last question
- what happens to security as AI becomes
stronger and stronger so I think a
really important question for all of us
to think about and such as a I becomes
become stronger and stronger when you
think about how attacker could actually
use AI and how we need to improve
security in the other systems the
attacker cognition for a human different
ways for example again I already we have
seen tyranny in public funding and also
different Lincoln University officials
have use the information from social
networks and so on and also some of you
may have seen that thermos you say I can
be used for such skill of automated
targeted manipulation for example is an
example from Cambridge and America which
has been essentially has helped to in
chunks election and I'll just mention
some of the words that we did a while
back showing that so this reduces the
consumer grade DCI devices helping and
figure become
more popular and they're fairly cheap
and they're used for lots of different
applications for example people usage
for better service today playing games
into and actually there is a party as
marketer for this VG PCI devices 4 and 3
just like your apps market register
party markets market reduce as well
so the question that we looked at is
what is an eg gaming app as malicious
what can I do
can electrically read your mind so we
did some studying English space where
the PCI to see whether the VCR actually
can be used as a side channel to the
brain where we showed that to apply as
the malicious attacker by specifically
crafting the app to provide certain
stimuli to the user and engaging the eg
signal back the attacker as you can
learn and you know sensible information
of other users such as who the user
knows where the user learned and what
kind of thank the the user uses and so
on so the key point here is such as the
more powerful this consumer grade PC
activators get and also simple powerful
the edge technology gets also the same
time the more powerful the attacks gets
as well because the attacker gets too
easy exactly the same technology that is
designed to help humans through outer
launch the attack so with this I think
one really important message for the
whole community is that with great power
becomes with great surgery
responsibility and also I want to
briefly mention another example from the
actually the medical device security is
that we did the first and multi device
security analysis in the prosecution
showed that a lot of these negative
items also have severe social
vulnerability and as a missile and also
with other researchers the follow-up
work FDA then in the beginning initially
for example at the time of this work a
pH guidance for medical device approval
has no mention of security and the last
year after
if another issues guidance
recommendation on 9025 security and
tsunami for AI for assistants we're
still at the very early stages in no
policy there's no regulations
so again information I strongly believe
that security will be one of the biggest
challenges in deploying AI and it's
really important to consider security
for AI from very early on and security
security is important and necessary for
future advancements of AI and also
tricky area is an interdisciplinary
community effort for summary requiring
even policy and and illegal in health as
well and there are lots and lots of open
questions for the future of AI and
security how to better understand what
security means for AI another new
systems how to detect whether a new
system has been fooled and compromised
how to build more resilient systems with
stronger guarantees how to make a
mitigated misuse of AI and worship the
visitor policy to ensure secure and
let's check out the big challenges
together thank you can I get a quick
ah ok let me start by introducing myself
i'm kim cornea an assistant professor at
Georgia Tech but I before I recently got
a PhD from MIT by general research
interesting systems in operating systems
in particular and system security in
general the thing of in terms of
security my career as a security
researchers thought about like I'll say
12 years ago when I was working as a
security agent in South Korea and in
terms of AI I have an interesting
background in fact I admitted as a
machine-learning PhD at MIT but I
changed it to security at the very first
day which turns out to be the worst
mistake that I've made according to this
one but in other word I was a little bit
yellow idea of what is AI but I'm
confident about the security so let me
let me talk about that little bit more
detail so Before we jump in to the topic
between our security in AI let me
clarify a little bit because the
security the term is ambiguous a ai-jen
videos both security and even worse so
here the security is basically software
and computer security in particular I
gonna talk a little bit about attackers
perspective not the security in general
in other one exclude any security ladies
issue that requires some human
involvement like flawed and fishing
video extremely good application for AI
but for the for the discussion are going
to exclude that in terms of AI instead
of talking about AEI itself are going to
talk about the mechanism like machine
learning and deep learning in particular
so anything the train based approach
sometimes their their behavior just
stochastic for instance these are all
well work well great out in practice but
sometimes there are too complex to
understand why they are working so I'm
going to talk about these in more detail
so for a folder proposal discussion are
going to make three points
so what AI can learn from security what
what particularly important thing about
security is a thing as an adversary we
typically call threat model and this
kind of practice is really important
because most of the machine learning
approach are talked about so
click research so insecurity if you say
it like we achieve 99.9% of accuracy in
your systems it's still insecure because
there's a point 1 percent of entire
component in your system the secondly so
what security can learn from AI one
thing I really like about AI is their
approach to measure and quantify the
progress of research sometimes there can
be a lot of interesting events like our
goal and chat which even people outside
of computer science can understand
what's going on and there are great
achievement of AI the last part well
what if AI takes off actually make me a
little bit worried because you don't put
a lot of opportunity for a tech early so
I'm going to talk about one of the
potential or tech that we have to worry
about when any I take self in our work
so how many people have our Tesla here
well interestingly okay there's one
so Kenny Kenny pill or hijack is Tesla
but it what is the best way to hijack
them what oh yeah this is better eg Swan
and seal that's right
oh yeah Hospital one good thing so
typical approach like you mentioned it's
a physical threat we put a wall in front
of Tesla so we can stop it and hijack
them much easier and we can make a
little bit intelligent we can we can
spook the sensor trouble we can target
it to the sensor of the Tesla by using
this laser or acoustic signals the
impact of this kind of approach is
really larger than physical set because
we can launch the attack remotely we can
even go further what if we can fool the
algorithms itself you can put a stop
sign but they are they're contradicting
each other so how can you decide since
probably they fall into the safe mode
try to stop the data eg ways to hijack
but you know how adversary actually
think about this problem the very
interesting way they actually put a
circle around the Tesla they can track
them you know when someone is a software
engineering we think about this
self-drive developing self-driving car
how many people think about this kind of
ocean
there are so many corner cases you never
think about before but adversary has the
opportunity to tackle the problem the
ones they fan out this one wickets point
of your system that can compromise your
system so who hold the strongest
adversary let me let me introduce this
guy called Loki Hart is one of the best
hacker in our generation arguably and he
did like fortune exploitation of all
major browsers and platform he actually
claimed more than millions of dollars in
total last three years including this
point one and half on past so the Google
has to pay so much money to envision
higher in Google project team zero had a
good chance to meet with him in this
close
conference among the high profile above
bounty hunter and a lot of people is
really wondering about what he is
actually doing what are the general
approach to find the vulnerability so
one one cloud ask it could you explain
how you actually found a vulnerability
this specific competition he said
because he never speaks English so his
friend I should translate his English
for him but what the interesting world
he actually said to all of them is
intuition in fact such a very surprising
bag but except there you're one bug that
he had to open the idea this reverse
engineering tools and just confirm that
his intuition is crack so you can see he
is exploitations unlike the normal
people he actually wrote the one or two
line to bypass all the way from the
browser's and Colonels and hypervisors
and launch the remote attacks so this
actually give a very interesting
observation in security so when we are
dealing with the security's your
particular exploitation writing and
patterning into the systems when you're
when you're designing a software defense
mechanism we try too hard to translate
our intuition into the methodology so
hope is that we can explain this kind of
search beyond a particular instance of
software but on the other hand what's
interesting here machine learning
particular is we are trying to infer
some of the intuition that we have by
putting a lot of data so hopefully we
can get a nice
parameters and weights and nice feature
for instance so what what's interesting
is if this mechanism do not work out
then what they are typically do is that
blame the data the quality of data here
let's collect more data and this kind of
interesting are a practice in machine
learning quite are the opposite of the
security so actually even worse than the
nominee security practice do not have
much data so example we are dealing with
the zero day vulnerability by definition
is not known to public but how could you
find those kind of vulnerability and
hypervisor vulnerability by using this
approach so I want to make this a
message to you guys so it's really
important to remember that attackers
really target a single which is the
point of entire systems if you talk
about nine nine nine percent it's still
not enough as a defense mechanism by
using AI so we really need to think
about the assumption that we have even
we typically call threat model when your
design particularly when you're applying
AI to the security so sometimes people
say hey you're not capturing intuition
because we are lacking the number of
features so why not just increasing
number of feature but in fact this is
actually increase the attack surface to
your system and likely to give a good
opportunity for attacker to bypass not
only just 5% penetration theory systems
so we are in system insecurity and
machine learning community we really
need a better way to directly translate
our intuition to the model and features
in more intuitive way so they on another
important thing that I want to say is
that something didn't happen we need a
better of the comprehensive way to
iterate this process so you can image
the model let's talk about the second
question what security can learn from AI
one thing I really like about AI is
their sequence of event that we can
understand very easily
starting from 1950 like tuning test or
tuning test and chess competitions and
self-driving car by DARPA and recently
jeopardy and go even even like last year
but actually the community took off even
further
in the Electronic Frontier Foundation
they recently announced this community
driven effort to quantify quantify and
measure the progress of AI in all
together so what what they proposing is
that they have a common set of data set
so once you publish the paper they're
going to extract the core algorithm and
put it all together if you're evaluating
this automatic way so once you put the
analysis algorithm in every single cell
field they're going to provide this nice
pretty figure so that someone who want
to use those mechanism again compare
pros and cons of those algorithm set
that other what happened to security in
particular private edge well probably
the problem is the security self is too
subjective the notion of the Security's
you really depend on the context that we
are talking and many many of in mostly
situations we don't even know what we
mean by measuring security typically
Security's binary decision it will
secure or insecure but sometimes the
security system can be insecure once we
found some zero-day vulnerability
outside so most of the notion with the
machine learning and many stochastic
approach is not quite well aligned with
the security in general so said that we
have a lot of interesting competition
out there like among GPS do is capture
the flag competition that really the top
hacker compete have to add each other
and we also had a kind of interesting
event that the computer instead of human
but instead of actually human typing
something that we can just watch how the
computer is play each other but in fact
I believe this is still influenced page
that we are is not like compatible to
what human doing in whatsoever so one
take out message from AI is that AI
field drive their research in various
landmark competitions which are easily
are approachable which is quite
approachable by common people outside
for computer science so in community
they is try to collect the public
resource for concept quantifying their
progress in research by sharing their
data data etc but what's interesting in
security is that a lot of people don't
want to share the data because say hey I
have a security incident by company
which kind of shame for them and a lot
of people consider that as one of the
confidential events internally and of
course ultimately security very
subjective but or what if we can tackle
the subfields of the security so that we
can at least some part of the security
can be quantified in various way in last
question well what a failure takes off
what are the potential security issue
again if I'm taking motional any good if
I remember when I take in machine
learning class many of my colleagues say
hey in this homework this works but I
don't know why you actually work it
sound like magic right this kind of a
trend and like feeling it should make me
very scared because in other words a lot
of people about a is everywhere in your
software still including your firewalls
are interested in intrusion detection
systems which means with so many unknown
software everywhere in particular if you
really worry about the apt attack which
call advanced persistent threat is
basically not the normal attack once by
script Kitty but the attack that
actually targeted specific people often
is backed by government and state and
some large organization etc like stealth
toxnet in fact if such unknown softwares
are everywhere you really making such
penetration easier is it a good question
we have to think about so one take-home
message take our message from this
question is that in in the future if we
have AI everywhere it basically now
previously we have to just work worried
about the implementation of particular
software but now we have to worry about
implementations
algorithms and data sets and their
training set as well just so much attack
surface you can easily penetrate into
and most of the time the program we do
not understand what they're doing but
attacker sometimes have more deep
knowledge about what what how system
works and if that's the case it was
attacker penetrate to your system but
you
really hard to detect even because
because we don't even understand what's
going on so in the future probably
accountability isn't one of the most
important I think that we need to have
as part of this research effort we're
going to present a project called a deep
s in black earth this coming month
you're basically given the amount where
we're going to keep interacting with the
antivirus software and manipulate that
then essentially bypass this AV software
out the outside without we don't know
anything about the antivirus software
eternal that turns out to be pretty easy
let me finish my talk by introducing two
ongoing efforts at Georgia Tech it's
just mind not mind my project we is a
interdisciplinary world between security
people's emotion learning so you're
quite similar to what Dunn was
explaining to us is basically about
adversarial machine learning but in the
context of antivirus software so we want
to detect we want to apply machine
learning based approach to identify the
malware so the another project it is
supported by Intel but another part
another project is ongoing work as well
is supported by NSF we want to even
generalize this approach even beyond the
malware so can we really find out the
interesting and visually in machine
learning algorithm that's applicable for
more broader applications as well
next time my name is Mike Walker I
recently joined Microsoft research from
DARPA where I ran cyber Grand Challenge
the AI versus AI computer security
competition that both my fellow
panelists competed in for those of you
in the room who are computer security
professionals I'm going to talk a little
bit about the history of the computer
security industry just to answer our
framing question what can a I learn from
security but for those of you who are
joining this talk directly from working
on AI who have maybe studied historical
lessons from the computer security
industry some of this may may be
relevant or useful to you so in 1996 we
thought smashing the stack for fun and
profit his first public description of
how to use very simple buffer overflow
attacks to take over remote programs on
remote servers and the temptation in
1996 when this was first described was
to say well now that we understand it we
could we can prevent this fast-forward
to 2011 when cyber crime was a 114
billion dollar problem for the global
economy this breakdown by trail of bits
was an attempt to look at every single
major break-in into business and root
cause what allowed the intrusion to
happen down to the flaws and then count
them and it turns out that the vast
preponderance of flaws used to enable
cybercrime well over a decade after this
was published where memory corruption
flaws like stack overflows so I think
that the teaching moment for AI is when
we see these first publications it is
possible to generate adversarial counter
examples and they work even when they're
printed on a piece of paper or it's
possible to poison training data sets is
to take these threats seriously and to
understand that it's not enough simply
to understand the trap but also to begin
working not just on how to prevent them
as we deploy AI systems but how to get
the knowledge about how to prevent them
out there this is the slide from
sandi quarks paper the honeymoon effect
where the research was done to look at
software flaws versus security issues
and over a really large set of software
the the key takeaway here is that we
kind of understand how bugs work in
systems during development we identify
bugs we drive bugs to zero
we ship but security flaws don't follow
that intuitive pattern where we drive
them to zero they actually happen later
and there's this period after after a
soft new piece of software shift called
the honeymoon where there are known
security flaws somewhere out of a
hundred days on average but sometimes it
can last for years but once there is a
tacher adaptation to a new system
security flaws take off and this
actually leads to a kind of an incorrect
selection bias where we believe that
newer software is more secure because it
hasn't been attacked yet and older
software that is in the middle of the
runaway ramp of the honeymoon fact seems
insecure whereas it is is actually not
and and I'd like folks working in the AI
field to consider that we may be in
honeymoon right now where we aren't
seeing active attacks or even reports of
active attacks but that does not mean
they're not in our future on the topic
of no reports of attacks this is one of
the slides from Mandaeans apt one report
which came out in the early 2000s and
mandiant was a company that was formed
or going in and doing breach
investigations in major companies in
this slide they've placed a yellow dot
every time they did a breach
investigation in an economic sector and
each one of those yellow dots is a
breach into a company that was running
modern security software that mostly had
good patched compliance and it was
defeated by intelligent adversary that
was working to steal information over
time but the thing to realize about this
slide is that when this report was
published in 2012-2013 then we had
reports of cyber attacks but for six
years there was silence and that silence
kind of comes
the prisoner's dilemma where no one
wants to be the first to speak out so I
would I would encourage everyone to say
that maybe we don't have a report of
active poisoning of an AI system in
production but please do not mistake a
lack of reporting for a lack of a
problem and the key here was the
development of a threat intelligence
industry where companies that were
affected by these sorts of attacks
shared information with each other about
threats so the time to build a threat
intelligence industry for AI is is now
before this happens if you are seeing
attacks on your production system if you
were seeing that smoke guaranteed you
are not alone so there's some golden
opportunities now in the AI and security
in general any software that's going to
serve as a gatekeeper to value will
eventually see the introduction of an
expert adversary the advanced persistent
threat someone who is studying that
software and learning how to defeat it
and just as much effort will be put into
defeating it as as stealth attackers
that the brake systems for profit always
put enormous effort into non detection
hence the apt one side attack detection
isn't free if we read no reports of
attacks on AI systems that can be an
artifact of no no attacks or it can be
an artifact of the fact that we are not
studying for attacks we haven't built
the sensors and we haven't built the
threat intelligence yet and the threat
intelligence industry took a long time
to build in the computer security arena
and finally techniques to defeat AI
systems will be discovered but we get to
choose how they're discovered if they
are discovered in the open and they are
published that we can start working on
mitigation and hopefully we can have a
much shorter timeline than some of the
initial timelines in the computer
security industry so that's my my
clothes for what what the AI field can
learn from the history of the computer
security industry what can the security
industry learn from AI
quite a bit I think that when we think
about encryption it's a it's a field
where we can predict how much work our
opponent has to do to decrypt our data
but there's a whole bunch of cycles in
the computer security industry we're
relying on predicting how much work an
adversary has to do to defeat us so one
example is the malware sandbox industry
the way that we learn about malware
right now is we we get feature
identification through dynamic analysis
by running malware inside an
instrumented sandbox an imitation
computer it turns out that sand print
paper raid in 2016 shows that you can
use machine learning to accelerate the
process of detecting sand boxes as a
matter of fact sand print was able to
achieve a classifier with 100% accuracy
for every malware sandbox that they
could download and 100% accuracy on
anything that they could test on the
Internet
even without access to source code and
because it's driven by AI its repeatable
that's a constant stealth evasion over
time so the security industry's
assumption of how much work we have to
do to get good feature extraction out of
malware has been defeated by an AI
system and that may continue to happen
but two other assumptions that the
computer security industry is making now
this is a fuzzer called AFL it's
published by Google and if you have a
computer on your desktop I guarantee you
that some critical software inside that
computer has had a security bug
discovered in it by AFL AFL has a page
called its trophy case where it just
lists software where it's found a
critical security flaw and it is
enormous AFL is one of the absolute best
security testing tools for unknowns
software flaws and this is a progression
of images that it created with with no a
priori knowledge just by studying traces
of how a JPEG library work and you can
see it kind of creating valid images
images that will render in a browser
what I want the surprising thing about
this is that there are no neural
networks involved there's no machine
a technique this is simply billing if
you're treating and feedback so there is
an enormous opportunity here for
adversarial systems that learn about
flaws and software to have a meeting of
minds with the AI field I think it's
already been said by my fellow panelists
that the ability to find exploitable
bugs in software right now is in
adversarial contest of the mind where
automated systems are still in their
infancy and are not competitive with
human beings we can see the the
successes in contests like chess and go
but for this contest there's enormous
opportunity for new research security
and AI in the future well I have to talk
about cyber Grand Challenge a brief
review this was a contest between
automated systems these automated
systems for place behind an air gap they
did ten minutes of compare 10 hours of
compute and they were all given the same
previously unexamined software where
they had to play an adversarial game
find and exploit ever flaws in their
opponent software defend against use of
those flaws in their own software and
it's worth noting that you know the kind
of the core technology stack automated
binary programming office one of the
luminaries of the field is up here with
us but that's a that's dawn system
Galactica on the far left and I'll tell
you one one anecdote that happened
during this competition somewhere in the
middle around ground fifty and by the
way this is all public data there's an
open corpus of every event that happened
during the contest you can go back and
replay it but Galactica discovered a new
flaw in software it wrote an exploit for
that flaw it smashed the stack for fun
not for profit and and and landed a
successful Stack Overflow attack against
all of its opponents and the next round
which was five minutes later the read
system deep read fielded a protected
stack version of its code so it had
changed all of the stack data structures
to non-executable using a stack of it
deployed the automatic patch but in the
next round
galactica exploited that patched version
by using what's known as a Roth attack
and it was an adaptation just to that
defense it was unique didn't use that
attack against any other system and
deep-red saw the adaptation of the
attacker system and responded by
fielding an IDs rule to prevent use a
specific memory address basically
blacklisted that memory address on the
wire and Galacta has adapted again and
started attacking a different flaw
unsuccessful at that time and deeper had
actually managed to through adversarial
cycles of counter adaptation actually
stopped an attack while it was happening
and I think that automated systems
engaged in adversarial cycles inside the
reaction speed of humans was kind of
first witnessed inside this prototyping
competition but we have to expect that
it's coming to the real world and while
that does sound a little bit scary I
would like to say that computer security
as a field has been dominated by the
structural disadvantages of human beings
doing defense human beings cannot react
to attacks as quickly as they happen
because they can't do the reasoning
quickly and they cannot look at the
scale of data that our that our networks
actually create but with machines those
structural disadvantages of speed and
scale and gone are gone and what you get
when you get an attacker defender
contest between AI is you get the
superior system wins and hopefully the
superior system in the future is going
to be the system is better engineered
and we're going to have an opportunity
to kind of upset this balance of power
that's been so dominated by an attack
for so long so I think with that I'm
going to hand this over to David all
right thanks very much everyone thank
you Mike we're going to come and have a
little bit of a panel discussion here we
have some structured discussion on each
of these points and then we'll end a
little bit early so if anyone wants to
have questions or can meet with the
panelists you'll that opportunity the
only thing is that Mike will have to
leave a little bit early so please come
on down and so I want to start off by
reviewing the pieces around how what can
I learn from secure
and I actually want to hark back to what
we as the security field would have done
when we discovered that people are
poisoning our training sets
I mean dawn you had like I think the
first paper I'm aware of that talked
about poisoning trains that's a decade
ago would you like to talk a little bit
about that and how people reacted to
that in the security industry thanks
and so yes there is you bring to
actually some housing to you my talk
about only briefly mention that didn't
have time to go into details actually
it's a great example also showing where
material you should be using security
applications so this very example we're
working with the worm attack so recently
we've seen some of the reasons very
recently warm attacks we're ready now
it's actually as a ransom where attack
but essentially in you know warm attack
the attacker exploits vulnerabilities in
software and then and take control over
the compromised house and then it's a
self propagate so once the host is
compromising that will very quickly go
try to attack as a vulnerable hosts and
hence these warmer types can happen
really really fast and so some of the
examples are in the past as a peak time
as the actually the attack can
compromise over like a thousands of
machines per second the top attitudes
and and then so the natural oils we want
to develop defenses actually we want
them to work in real time and so on so
then one way to do that is by trying to
generate one signatures to detect with
warm attachment as you can block these
warm attacks then this actually can be
viewed as a learning problem where you
have a label examples where you have the
exploits warm attractions so you have
essentially these 50 sequences
developers ones and also you have normal
traffic generation is really borders now
attack and then the course to learn a
classifier to then given a packet our
sequence surface to determine whether
it's a one-man tacular you should block
is economic traffic solution rights to
now you're here as you can see so also
the interesting things that's here
actually the attacker also had to
control
I'm showing what in some senses like
invoices it was examples you'll see and
so on so then also as you learn the
classifier the attacker actually has an
interaction with the with the classifier
as the attacker teacher if it's a target
being plaster can actually change
morphix attack and try to make the
classifier ineffective so as you can see
this actually as an interactive game and
in this case then essentially the the
changing state has the labels as you can
see they actually could be poisoned and
where she studied the very settings
where the classifier can actually learn
the real model and hence and also as you
can see in this in this example it's
actually really expensive for the
classifier to learn the real model
because payments at the essence if the
classifier integral model and then then
it gives the attacker more time to
propagate to compromise other machines
and so the more intuition that it takes
the the classifier is the winner to
learn the right classifier then
essentially the less chance of actually
being able to protect the vulnerable
hosts and in some of our work we
actually give some lower bounds in the
impossible of some of the highness
results in this purpose for interactive
game to actually use it to write to the
engine so that seems like a case where
an example of the honeymoon effect you
were talking about Mike so well I'm
curious about Mike is let's suppose you
were given operational responsibility
for one of these systems that dawn
techniques are going after well what
would you do to look for this stuff so I
think it was Sergey Broadus who said
that defense is the child of offense and
you can see this in in the way we named
mitigations you know stack overflow
defenses are named after the attack they
prevent so I think that open publication
of attack research like Don's doing has
to be immediately followed by detection
and mitigation work so anyone who is
running a machine learning based system
that is acquiring untrusted data from
the outside that's going to be used to
training needs to be searching for these
attacks
and and using the open publication of
data or the open publication of
techniques to train their detection and
attacking prototyping like red teaming
to make sure that that detection is
working
yeah and tae-soo I really liked your
point about security we're trying to
codify intuitions right and now
especially your point was like that's
almost sort of like you know learning
from data and trying to turn into
classifiers if you think about like the
intuitions we need in order to detect
these kinds of attacks and create the
accountability you were asking for like
what what do you think would look like
in today's world there's a pretty good
question but in other words you how to
answer in general but accountability
argument it'll want to something happen
for example my motion learning base
about pitching system is not working and
we need some clue about why it's not
working so that I can actually come back
to the systems either you implement
again where we need more different set
of data to can cover it but we don't
know what to do next
other than nivel increasing number of
the data potentially you can train with
a new folder new model I think one thing
that is very interesting thing about
emotional learning approach is that
people start with the feature
engineering this is kind of a way to
encode the intuition to to the motion
learning those algorithms but we need a
more direct way to represent this one
other than this feature engineering the
real plane and I like to point out
feature engineering because actually
rising it on I thought really
interesting about your work on
adversarial learning the fact that
you're the epsilon point zero zero five
and you can completely screw up the pong
player but did that surprise you that
such a small perturbation was actually
reduced we resulting like an incredible
effect and that's a very good question I
think yes and now I mean so we knew that
to these tips reinforcement in England
agents too can be very easily forgiven
past experience as I was you examples in
other domains we knew that it can be
beautiful but yes actually we didn't
expected it can be so easily fooled and
also I didn't have time to talk about
some more in
investigation I think one thing a really
is telling us is the current deep
learning this new network architecture
even though they have been making
creative entrance but really they're now
high learning the right representation
this representation is a very brittle
they are really very vulnerable to this
type of a betrayal attacks and so on so
just means that to the small work force
to figure out what is actually the right
architecture is the right solution
surprise and I think that's interesting
because it goes back to you know we're
going to evolve how we account for these
things and the one things I like Mike
about your data for the mounting answers
that's from Incident Response so if you
could just speculate a little bit about
legends and respond is going to look
like in a world where we're talking
about this I'm going to come in and I
have to figure out what my model miss
trained and not just did someone get
into my box what I think of one of my
previous responses I got away with a
security industry trick which as I said
trusted sources and of course Trust is
never binary you know how trusted is the
source of the data so Incident Response
for a poison attack is going is going to
involve a lot of where did this data
come from how is it influenced and I
think the hard part is going to is going
to be the differentiation between
intentional malfeasance on training data
and accidental there's this this term of
art in the security industry a bugged or
which is rather than inserting an
intentional logical access path you know
if my user name is Bob let me in you
leave behind a flaw that is plausibly
deniable and that flaw can be exploited
by an attacker even one who left it in
and the problem with bug Doris's is
again this retroactive assignment of
intent so the really tricky thing about
poisoned data is going to is going to be
the differentiation between intentional
and accidental malfeasance and the
ability in the tools to prove it so
going back to my example around Zillow
if I'm controlling the Zillow algorithm
and I magically make my house go up by
$50,000 this week your point is that
maybe Zillow won't even know it was
intentional maybe I just tweaked some
weight somewhere is that what you're
saying it's going to be very difficult
even if first you need the toolset to
say this is the data that caused the
change and then the second is going to
be an attacker created this data and
predicted the effect and one thing I
think is another thing we can learn from
security industry is actually some work
that you've done tae-soo on the sort of
the fun looking at even supposedly
isolated systems like SGX
and inferring data about them just from
observations I wanted you to talk a
little bit about that so when you're
chatting with our Intel engineer one
interesting thing what was on
interesting technology called interest
chip
it's a great potential to hug for
example interest rate is one of the
hardware feature that actually hide your
data so that you can do those
confidential computation in the cloud
but the interesting thing about this
about a lot of industry is a great
demand on hiding those data but they
still want to provide these services
outside so for them the now in this
current software model we reconsider the
data you really important but at the
same time they want to serve and somehow
obviously confront the contradicting
goals actually drives a lot of
researching security community that is
there anyway side channel for instance
way to insert those model out of those
actually isolated I'm crazy for instance
because you want to look there recently
publishing when using security and and
what was nice about that as it showed
you know we think this thing is a black
box we think this thing has certain
guarantees and you show that actually
doesn't it's right on so with that I'd
like to move on to the what can security
learn from AI and I think we saw some
great examples across all three of your
talks are like what are some ways we can
learn from AI and what we're doing again
types I want to start with you and sort
of talk about the competition I mean
both you and Don you know participants
are part of a grand challenge do we need
to have more of those is that you know
the way forward you know what do you
think so okay this is a player so I
joined that patchy to see quite late
because that happened after I joined
George
Ted I don't have permission to start but
we join about two years ago before the
final so I spent a whole lot of time
like engineering but what interesting
outcome of these opportunities that we
thought there should be a lot of
breakthrough in program analyst analysis
and the way we play the game and for
example not planning's and etc but the
end at the end of the day every single
player are doing the same so for example
everyone is using ASL everyone is using
some form of the symbol executions
everyone is j:3 those are the server but
we we don't kind of expect we kind of
expect more than this but at the end it
means they're competing with the quite
similar they took the quite similar
approach that we understand yeah and
like I know you have two leaves I'll let
you sir feel that as well
well the that a convergence of approach
is what we get out of Grand Challenges
when you say anyone in the world can
play there's there's no barrier to
competition
it's a prototyping challenge what came
out of the DARPA self-driving car
challenge is kind of what came out of
cyber Grand Challenge which is we have a
kind of a confirmed prototype design for
what the state of the art is and I think
for an AI audience what's amazing about
that state of the art is there's both no
really effective known public
applications deep learning yet and
there's a corpus that is mostly unsolved
that's really well groomed of unknown
software very small examples with with
flaws in them and that corpus I think
the time to do something like this again
is when we move the needle on that
corpus from I think 20 percent were
solved with the final event something
like 50 percent whatever technology
causes that jump and maybe it will be AI
that's probably the trigger to try a
competition like this again so let me
add a little bit about like
quantification of the progress one great
outcome of this package in general is
just data set so these a
you see though the folding papers and
simple execution paper and be here the
reference model because we kind of
understand that all the subjects that we
already applied we have already we have
a good experience of the software now if
somebody proposed new fighting strategy
then that party's issue data so the
reference model you see it on any
thoughts on this yeah I think here also
I guess a little bit back to takes us to
the point earlier I think for these
challenges it's a press well might be
the amazing job for organizing the
challenge absolutely absolutely and but
still like a for every challenge it has
to make certain decisions because you
have to limit the scope you have to
really set the stage so I think and the
for example we have other techniques
that it's given the requirements of the
challenge we couldn't use them so I
think that's also one of the reasons
potentially why different teams also
choice similar approaches but and then I
also could start to take the other point
earlier about and I think right so in
machining again where I think there is
also positive edge about this
competition as essentially a marker for
progress on one hand I think we
absolutely increases I think as human
beings that we also social animals in
some sense that actually helps with the
community have a clear title to make
improvement but on the other hand I
think will be more effort even more
community effort should actually go into
what it's actually needed there what
would be the best competition to set up
what has the best tasks as a whole
community that we should line up these
other you know the milestones these are
the tasks that we should consider a
material again I might get an absolutely
amazing fantastic job organizing the
grand challenge and I know personally
how much effort that he has to t in
designing these challenges and I think
that is putting a ton of resources in
this but actually I think it going
forward to we should consider this as a
community effort so it's not this our
only
like the shoulder other now like it's a
Microsoft so I think these are actually
in some sense from what we have seen so
these are great drivers for the whole
community of big progress but also we
know the risks if we design the wrong
path for example in some I think you're
even in Princes Parker earlier I think
it's talking about how teacher says you
can affect you know if you just report
performance members and reducers
actually you can mislead the community
into ground directions our focus on one
person's very actually a lot of people
regret about articles in Africa it's a
great advantage but in terms of actually
integer making progress measuring
linking in progress right there are lots
of questions there as well and I think
going forward actually love to see as a
whole community we have a bigger
community average so that these
especially important has and are just in
a recipe and the sugar of a few
individuals actually be a much more
community effort and with the community
also putting more resources all right
don't I have to go
I've already thought CGC was designed to
be computers play the game of hackers
and that game CTF was kind of designed
by the hacker community so it was an
attempt to bring machines into something
that people did but in terms of
designing competition or using
competition to drive the
state-of-the-art in computer security
forward for AI forward I agree
completely that there's there's a whole
bunch of work we could do there and the
power of competition is incredible so I
would love to hear actually new
proposals for how to use competition to
accomplish that purpose
all right thanks very much Mike and with
that I'm going to switch to the last
thing which is what is AI what is a
security look like after AI happens and
the thing I love about both your answers
is they're very different very very
different right I love the the notion of
what a new advanced persistent threat is
and then dawn from your talk I got that
that Vance Kristin Fred might be living
inside my head
oh I guess one thing I find interesting
is when we're working on something like
this where it's still a little bit
earlier it have the curve like the brain
computer interfaces and I'll start with
you don how do you think about the
limitations are sort of transient like
today's headsets have certain
limitations but they'll get better
versus limitations that are like really
fundamental like how do you think about
that when you're framing research in
this kind of area very good question I
think so the important message I really
wanted to get through as as ours you
only using the PC I work that which is
as one example as as we move forward
already we can talk about where you can
have things and so we will have more and
more expenses around us more and more
advanced the sensory sensor and
essentially we want the eye to be our
assistance but at the same time that
means that we are going to know more and
more about Al's as well and and then
this of course on one hand it to
facilitate us but on the other hand a
really opens a big attack surface I
think that we have not really
experienced with in the past that we
have not anticipating the past where the
attacker could launch new and completely
new types of attacks and that this is
one example how again with the MoMA a I
and the community are penetrating with
our daily life the entire society there
will be new types of attacks that we've
never even imagined and here we're not
even talking about AI a self is becoming
new intelligence aha area itself can
turn really humanistic hacker could
misuse AI to launch a new type of attack
so I really like that dawn because
there's a question of the harry shum
fireside chat around what will the
business look like after AI takes off
and then so ties to what I love about
your advancements and thread is what is
the mandiant of the future you know the
apt hundred the future going to look
like so first of all the the reason that
we are speaking a little bit differently
about how you see how you define
security in the future the one thing I
was focusing on is about defending a
particular company particular
organization as a defense mechanism if
we apply
AIE based approach with the our
traditional defense mechanism like into
detection system and firewalls any kind
of defense mechanism you can imagine
then a lot of people rely on those
mechanism and most of them now start
working as a driven by data and if those
kind of data I should be collecting
somehow and most of them has a
probabilistic meaning which means if you
a lot of people start relying on those
kind of security mechanisms it seems
like working in normal cases in most of
the time but in terms of apt advanced
persistent threat so if I start
targeting the particular person in the
world
you're really preventing that it's kind
of questionable because we don't know so
whether a kind of new attempt is really
can bypass the machine learning model
our may deploy in the real world
so this detection ring we little bit
care about the apt kind of attacks in
the future all right well we're going to
wrap up our discussion there just to let
everyone know these are the questions we
talked about and as a next step if
you're in security reach across the
aisle find an AI person and if you're in
AI reach across the aisle and find a
security person because I think we've
heard there's a ton of new techniques to
apply lots of great questions and lots
of new things to do and our panelists
will be here for people who want to sort
of have some discussion afterwards and
thank you very much for your time
thank you everyone
[Applause]